la mort de romy schneider un arrêt
cardiaque brise l'un des plus beaux
personnages du cinéma français malween
les forces britanniques prête à l'assaut
de port stanley l'argentine pourrait
faire appel à l'air militaires
étrangères annonce le président d'elcs
kerry le pape en grande-bretagne fraîche
l'oecuménisme et l'unité des églises
chrétiennes ouverture du congrès du
centre des démocrates sociaux lutte
serrée pour la succession de jean
lecanuet madame monsieur bonsoir elle
avait pour elle le talent la beauté et à
43 ans cette forme de maturité alourdi
par le malheur romy schneider est morte
ce matin d'un arrêt cardiaque due
vraisemblablement à une absorption
conjuguer d'alcool et de barbituriques
le substitut du procureur de la
république a signé le permis d'inhumer
le médecin légiste ayant conclu à une
mort naturelle de 6,6 à la passante du
sans-souci romy schneider avait su en
une cinquantaine de films surtout
français forget des personnages de
femmes qui touchait toujours par la
sincérité l'acharnement au travail qui
servait son talent c'est ainsi que romy
schneider est parmi nous comme le
prouvent france roche
ces armoires pleines de prix
d'interprétation son bureau plein de
scénarios et de proposition de contrat
romy d'or
elle n'a jamais je crois dormi vraiment
tranquille toujours inquiètes soucieuse
de faire mieux ayant peur de décevoir
jamais rassasié de succès est aussi
régulièrement frappé par un destin qui
semblait inévitable remis a subi toutes
les épreuves qu'a roman mélo aurait pu
proposer pour montrer qu'on peut être
riche belle célèbre et souffrir beaucoup
je n'arrive pas à voir un homme et un
enfant en vacances
plus ça va je me dis que c'est pas grave
je sais très bien que c'est avant ce
grand enfant pour lui et pour moi
quand je dis je veux le garder je me
demande si c'est pas lui qui me garde sa
vie était une tempête elle passait de la
haute vague vertigineuse du triomphe au
creux effrayant de l'abandon et de
l'échec
à 20 ans elle était la petite fiancée de
l'allemagne à 25 ans elles étaient
honnis par son pays et chercher à se
faire par amour
une seconde carrière en france
vous avez retrouvé le moment où vous
aviez quitté l'allemagne vous n'étiez
pas encore reconnue en france et où il y
avait quand même deux bonnes années il
ya absolument
mais après c'est un peu dur et bien
entendu on commence à se poser les
questions commencent à voir beaucoup
moins confiance en soi même on a peur on
est très angoissé et on se dit bon ben
on veut plus de toi qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire ou vêtus comprend
sa carriére par hollywood la paix après
avoir attendu plusieurs années d'être
épousé par alain delon elle découvre en
rentrant d'amérique un bouquet de roses
et une lettre il est parti avec une
autre sa carrière ralentie à nouveau
elle rencontre un metteur en scène de
théâtre un reee mayenne il est marié se
sépare de sa femme l'épousé ils ont un
fils david
mais remirent devenu star leur vie
divergent il divorce pour garder david
elle abandonne à mayenne la moitié de sa
fortune quelques années plus tard il se
suicide
l'année dernière on promène remis
d'urgence en clinique on lui enlève un
rein à peine convalescente elle apprend
que son fils s'est éventré en escaladant
une grille c'était un petit soldat
courageux effrayer qui gagnaient les
batailles couvert de blessures de
blessures dont on retrouve les traces
dans les héroïnes de ses films dont elle
jouait trop bien les tourments
être mais mais un jour à la campagne
avec mes fruits mais arbres et ma fille
et vivre
oh
le ministre de la culture jack lang a
rendu hommage à romy schneider nous
sommes privés d'une amie at il dit
qu'elles vivent longtemps en nous mêmes
à travers les rôles qu'elle avait marqué
de son empreinte
puisque ainsi vont les choses de la vie
c'est la fête du rugby ce soir au parc
des princes et sur antenne 2 puisque
dans 20 minutes à peu près comment sera
la finale du championnat de france agen
rencontre bayonne
l'ambiance est déjà chaude au parc des
princes où le président mitterrand doit
arriver sous peu
du très beau rugby en perspective entre
deux équipes qui pratiquent l'une et
l'autre un rugby de tradition puisqu'il
y à 39 ans déjà et s'étaient affrontés
au sommet rendez vous donc tout à
l'heure après ce journal avec roger
couderc pierre albaladejo et pierre
salviac en direct donc sur antenne 2
la guerre des malouines semble tourner
ce soir al'avantage de la grande
bretagne en tout cas sur le plan
militaire
après avoir repris dans la nuit d'hier
port darwin et l'aérodrome de goos green
les troupes britanniques poursuivent
leur progression vers la capitale port
stanley port stanley ou comme vous
pouvez vous allez le voir sur ces images
d'origine argentine
l'adc argentine depuis plusieurs jours
faisait face au harcèlement de
l'aviation et de la flotte britannique
les britanniques seraient prêts ce soir
a lancé l'assaut
l'état-major argentin a reconnu ce matin
que les britanniques avaient réussi
c'est l'expression employée à consolider
leur tête de pont et que 4000 à 4500
hommes avaient débarqué ce qui sur le
plan stratégique veut dire en fait vie
de londres qu'avec port darwin les
britanniques ont conquis un atout
important verna rap fait que moi cette
nouvelle position procure trois
avantages aux britanniques d'abord il
dispose maintenant d'une base terrestre
pour leurs avions donc des avions des
styles harrier qui peuvent opérer à
partir du sol même des malouines
deuxième avantage à nouveau point de
débarquement pendant wind est un port en
eau profonde ont pu débarquer des hommes
et du matériel
et puis troisième avantage c'est la
deuxième des dix ans la deuxième en
importance car nous en argentine sur les
malouines qui était donc enlevé hier par
les anglais et sur le plan psychologique
je crois que c'est très important mais
le plus dur maintenant reste à faire
c'est la reprise de port stanley à ça le
plus dur c'est la reconquête de port
stanley port stanley c'est le gros
morceau pour les britanniques
c'est la principale garnison guînes avec
7000 à 9000 ans il sait pas exactement
mais au moins 7000 hommes des troupes
d'élite et surtout beaucoup de soldats
professionnels beaucoup de militaires de
métier et jusqu'à présent les
britanniques n'ont pas tellement été
confronté à ces militaires de métier
mais plutôt à des conscrits qui n'ont
pas eu l'ardeur peut-être qu'on pouvait
en attendre
et puis là huit semaines maintenant que
les argentins sont installés donc à port
stanley ils ont pu consolider leur
position ils ont du matériel lourd de
l'artillerie et peut-être même des
missiles mais portales le symbole car
aussi bien pour lui que pour buenos
aires qui qu'apporte cette année tient
les malouines et c'est en ce soir ce qui
se passe exactement sur le terrain
alors si mes camarades de la bbc veulent
bien mais façon on va faire un rapide
point sur la carte
alors pour se lancer à l'heure actuelle
les britanniques poursuivent leur
mouvement d'encerclement en deux
directions à partir du nord d'abord où
des marines combien progresser sur un
terrain pourtant difficile à partir du
sud ensuite où les parachutistes du 2e
bataillon ont repris leur progression à
partir de ford ar wid vers port stanley
sur la seule route praticable de livres
c'est le classique mouvement en
tenailles mais parce que la soupe promet
d'être difficile ans attend un
débarquement de renforts britannique sur
la côte orientale de l'île
ici des troupes qui devrait appuyer
l'offensive menée de l'autre côté de
port stanley alors ses troupes et bien
un stage essentiellement des 3000 hommes
qui seraient à bord du queen elizabeth 2
qui ne devrait pas tarder à arriver sur
le théâtre d'opérations on dit même que
or est déjà là et que les deux régiments
qui sont à bord à savoir la garde
galloise et les fameux gurkhas donc ces
régimes aurait déjà été transférés à
bord des péniches d'assaut merci bernard
à l'état-major argentin a annoncé que
son aviation continue d'attaquer le
secteur de gouges green sans reconnaître
que la région est maintenant contrôlée
par les britanniques à buenos aires où
l'on célébrait aujourd'hui le jour de
l'armée de terre
son chef le président galtieri a dans
son discours brandi la menace d'un appel
à des forces armées étrangères de buenos
aires bruno albin le chef de l'état sur
les thématiques traitées américaine est
prévue avec m
l'organisation des états américains a
demandé par ailleurs aux états unis de
lever immédiatement les sanctions
vis-à-vis de l'argentine et de
s'abstenir de toute aide matérielle à la
grande bretagne les états unis sont donc
de plus en plus isolés de leurs alliés
latino américains la guerre est passée
aujourd'hui au second plan de la visite
du pape en grande bretagne même si bien
sûr elle est présente dans tous les
esprits
pour la première fois de l'histoire un
pape est un primat anglican ont prié
ensemble aujourd'hui l'image même de
l'unité de l'église chrétienne
françois cau renaît sous les voûtes de
la cathédrale de canterbury orgue et
trompette ont salué ce matin l'arrivée
de jean paul 2 au siège de l'église
anglicane seule personnalité non
religieuse dans le coeur le prince
charles
un service oecuménique sans consécration
dit communion mais une récitation du
credo est une bénédiction commune du
pape et du primat anglican
après avoir échangé deux baisers de paix
de réconciliation
jean paul ii et l'archevêque 36 se sont
longuement agenouillé devant l'autel du
transept près de l'endroit où thomas
becket était tombé en 170 sous le coup
des hommes de main du roi henri ii
à l'issue de cette cérémonie que nous
allons voir dans un instant sur les
pelouses entourant les vieux murs de la
cathédrale
le pape mèches blanches souvent les
mains encombré de petits bouquets a été
acclamé par plusieurs milliers de
fidèles avant d'être accueillis cet
après midi sur le grand stade de wembley
au nord de londres par plus de cent
mille personnes
voici l'arrivée du pape au stade de
wembley
jean paul ii et qu'on célébrait une
messe sur ce stade milieu de 2500 prades
les etats unis sont prêts à entamer
immédiatement les négociations avec
l'union soviétique sur la réduction des
armements stratégiques
c'est ce que le président reagan a
déclaré aujourd'hui sans donner plus de
détails le président reagan doit
entreprendre la semaine prochaine la
tournée européenne la plus importante de
sa présidence puisqu'il viendra assister
au sommet des pays industrialisés à
versailles et au sommet de l'otan à bomy
c'est une tournée arabe délicate qu
entreprend aujourd'hui le ministre
français des relations extérieures
claude cheysson avant la tunisie et la
libye
messieurs cheysson est ce soir en arabie
saoudite c'est la première fois
c'est la première mission arabe
entreprise par le chef de la diplomatie
française depuis la visite du président
mitterrand en israël outre le problème
palestinien les saoudiens sont vivement
préoccupé des conséquences de la
victoire récente de l'iran sur l'irak un
contexte politique complexe qui donne
donc son relief à cette visite à ryad
l'elysée et matignon pour donner
l'artillerie lourde contre le quotidien
américain le herald tribune qui publie
aujourd'hui le compte rendu d'un
entretien entre le président mitterrand
et plusieurs journalistes américains
avant le sommet de versailles selon cet
entretien répondant à une question sur
la situation économique le chef de
l'état n'exclut pas une possible
dévaluation du franc ou un décrochage du
système monétaire européen
le service de presse de l'elysée a
catégoriquement démenti aujourd'hui que
monsieur mitterrand est évoquée au même
abordé le sujet le journaliste américain
lui persiste et signe et ajoute que ses
confrères présents à l'entretien peuvent
confirmer l'exactitude de son compte
rendu de son côté le premier ministre
pierre mauroy a fait publier un
communiqué selon lequel sa ligne de
conduite et la consigne reçue du
président reste inchangé la défense du
franc le congrès du centre des
démocrates sociaux a commencé ses
travaux aujourd'hui à versailles
les militants du cds qui est l'une des
trois composantes de l'udf
f doivent d'ici demain choisir le
successeur de jean lecanuet alors que
souvent les congrès politiques ne font
qu'entériner des choix déjà faits cette
fois ci aux cds c'est le suspense entier
remet une vie est en train de refaire
son handicap sur celui qui lie à
seulement quelques semaines et est
assuré de l'emporter
bernard stasi murmure ici à versailles
que 20% des bâtons du cds sont encore
hésitants et que ce sont ces 20 % qui
pourrait bien faire la différence en
faveur de l'ancien ministre de
l'agriculture
demain après midi ce qui voudrait dire
alors que les centristes aurait
définitivement choisi leur temps est
fondamentalement opté pour un ancrage
plus giscardien vers l'udf la
philosophie du centre traditionnel à
d'ailleurs été défendu au cours de la
première journée de ce congrès par jean
lecanuet président depuis 19 ans et
président sortant jean lecanuet héros du
jour à l'applaudimètre
je crois à la nécessité des grands
courants simplificateur et qui rassemble
personne n'a dit qu'il fallait sortir de
l'udf parmi les candidats ils sont dans
l'opposition et pour l'udf il shot que
le cds soit plus fort et plus rayonnant
ils ont raison et permettez au président
de l'udf de dire qu'ils adressent le
même voeu aux autres composantes de
l'udf
car plus nous serons nombreux et chacun
selon notre tempérament attractif plus
grandes seront pour la france les
chances de se redresser et d'avoir une
capacité d'alternative démocratique
pourtant les jeux ne sont pas faits
bernard stasi affirme encore avoir des
cartes en main pour éviter le risque de
voir le centre se diluer dans l'udf au
point d'y perdre une partie de sa
personnalité mais monsieur mais une
grille non plus n'a pas dit son dernier
mot et il est vrai qu cds on est souvent
plus sensibles au discours cosider
suite demain le congrès de la cfdt s'est
terminée aujourd'hui à metz la
résolution finale portant sur la
politique d'action dans les trois ans à
venir a été adopté à une large majorité
et c'est sans surprise que de mon maire
a été réélu secrétaire général jacques
chérèque reste secrétaire général
adjoint les trois spéléologues bloqués
depuis six jours dans une grotte de
haute-savoie sont vivants tentant le
tout pour le tout les sauveteurs ont
réussi à les rejoindre ce matin mais il
faudra deux à trois jours pour les
dégager
place au sport maintenant est d'abord le
tennis à roland garros aujourd'hui la
grande attraction était le match du
jeune élève contre son modèle le match
de guy forget contre jimmy connors
connors a gagné en quatre manches mais
forget qui avait réussi à éliminer
nastase est parvenu à ravir un set à la
tête de série numéro un roger zabel un
cogneur jimmy connors c'est bien vous
allez voir sur cet échange que guy
forget n'a dans ce domaine rien à envier
à celui qu'il admire le plus et dont il
s'est sans doute inspiré
pour bien apprécier cette puissance nous
revoyons au ralenti les accélérations de
ce garçon de 17 ans qui pendant deux
jours aura fait vibrer le public de
roland garros après avoir perdu les deux
premières manches 6-2 6-3 cet après midi
guy forget s'est offert le luxe de
gagner la troisième au tie break
et ceci après avoir sauvé une balle de
match quand on est capable de jouer de
cette manière et de m jimmy connors à un
mètre de la balle
il est évident que l'on ne peut être que
promis un très bel avenir
seulement dans une rencontre de tennis
de ce niveau c'est souvent l'expérience
qui prime et la jimmy connors n'en est
pas à son premier grand tournoi comme
c'est le cas pour son adversaire qu'il
bat finalement 6-2 6-3 6-7 6-1 après une
partie que guy forget abordés et
discutés sans aucun complexe
je suis rentré d'abord je veux en disant
que j'avais rien à perdre et que je vais
faire mes meilleurs matches donc je vais
pas me soucier que ce soit dit miku nord
ce soit notre joueur donc
je suis entré dans notre révolte à des
fins de confiance publié un grand court
central malgré connors c'est sûr quand
on y pense un petit peu inconsciemment
mais
et je suis de faire abstraction du peu
de tout ça est ce que connors pour vous
reste le même après avoir joué contre
lui
oui il reste le même seulement moi
j'essaie de me dire que j'ai progressé
aussi donc c'est un petit peu normal que
que j'arrive à l'ennui un petit peu mais
pour moi ça sur quand même un grand
champion et le poster va rater sur les
murs de la chambre encore toujours se
jouerait il y aura tiercé demain à
longchamp dans le prix du lac qu'un bref
soit si ces pronostics nous les
découvrons ensemble 5 le 7 le 12 le 6 le
8 le 17 le 11 et le neuf le temps
maintenant alain gillot-pétré allez-vous
faire briller le soleil demain c'est pas
moi c'est le bon dieu mais oui le soleil
radieux manoeuvrant même un soleil d'été
sur la majeure partie de la france toute
une autre carte on est à peu près c'est
du beau temps presque partout sauf bien
entendu il ya toujours des nuages
quelque part de la vendée aux pyrénées
est assez nuageux avec un peu de pluie
sur l'extrême sud ouest et des orages
dans le lot c'est tout à fait normal
avec la chaleur qu'il fera demain c'est
le même temps pour après-demain j'oublie
tout de suite la chaleur de demain ça
monte encore sans grands commentaires
une vingtaine de degrés c'est le minimum
et oui sur les côtes de la manche
maximum 28° à marseille un petit bout
d'agenda on termine vite demain dimanche
30 mai 2010 travaillant plus lever 5h55
coucher 21h42 c'est la pentecôte
finalement aussi la fête de saint
ferdinand
à 23h15 antenne 2 dernier avec hervé
claude merci d'avoir suivi ce journal à
demain 20h et maintenant bon lui de vie